hello everyone and welcome to the second
episode of connecting the dots and today
with me i've got cassidy williams
cassidy thank you so much for hanging
out with us today
thank you for having me i'm excited i am
just tickled pink you uh you chose to
come and join us on here i think this is
gonna be an absolute blast um
so i mean
i i feel like you're one of the people
who needs no introduction but maybe we
should do just for the the sake of
anyone who's been living under a rock or
doesn't go on twitter or isn't familiar
with tick tock um
you want to give a little bit of an
introduction for yourself
hello everyone i exist
um uh i'm a
i'm a dev experienced engineer with
jason at netlify i make beams on the
internet
and
that's really the high level thing i
could i could go into more detail but i
figure we will throughout this whole
thing yeah i think that's
that's our whole goal today so um for
everyone in the chat thank you so much
for hanging out with us today the the
goal of what we want to talk about today
is um
like the premise for the show is that i
think
a lot of people are looking for work
right now it's been a hard year uh tech
is getting busier and busier there are
more and more people who are are moving
into the field through boot camps
through traditional means through
non-traditional means just studying on
their own um
and that means that there are a lot of
folks who are trying to get that first
role and so what we want to do on the
show is talk to people like yourself who
have a
like a stellar career you know you've
done a lot of amazing things that we'll
talk about and you've got an amazing
network that we'll also talk about
but kind of rewind that a little bit and
talk about how you got those first steps
and how you started that journey and
also the part that i find most
interesting is
when we're talking about a tech career
what is it that we're able to bring to
it that's not tech training so not being
a developer not being computer science
major but what do we bring from the rest
of ourselves that gives us an advantage
that gives us that opportunity to go
further and do more with our tech career
um
so
i guess to to jump right into this
how did you like what was your journey
from like not in tech to first tech job
how did you how did you get started
um so i have a very traditional
background i actually have a cs degree
um and studied computer science i
started coding when i was a teenager and
and played around with things started
building stuff i took ap computer
science in high school and then got uh
got my computer science degree um but in
college i kind of did have a shift that
introduced me to the tech industry um
that i think was significant where i
started doing internships and stuff and
and
uh i would say probably my junior year
was when i really started getting
connected and that's when i started
actually networking with people which i
think was the biggest shift of all
because um
once i started going to hackathons and
conferences and meetups and just any any
events that i could go to and granted i
went to iowa state university excellent
school loved it there um but iowa is
kind of in the middle of nowhere and so
a lot of people think oh dang i have to
be in san francisco to go to the meetups
and stuff you don't you can be in the
middle of iowa and and still go to these
things and so um
i i started getting connected by just
emailing with people going to office
hours and saying hey i heard you're
connected with this person can i get an
introduction just starting to kind of
put out feelers getting involved with
online communities and doing that just
really opened so many doors for me where
uh my junior year of college i was
invited to speak at the white house and
my sister and i both ended up speaking
at the white house to talk about
inclusion and technology and stuff with
with a bunch of other uh women our age
which was an amazing opportunity
and people who i met there i ended up
following up emailing them and then one
of them ended up becoming a mentor to me
um and then that next summer i interned
out in silicon valley and i called it my
summer of networking because i truly
just i went to either a hackathon or a
meetup at least twice a week the entire
summer i was just concerned
where's most people
most people are having their summer of
love you had your summer of linkedin
requests
but actually that's exactly how i
described it i was just like i want to
get 300 connections on linkedin this
summer alone like i i set that as a goal
but it's true
i know i know it's i know it's like the
nerdy thing to do at a summer internship
but i it
it changed the trajectory of my career
really because absolutely i was able to
get connected to so many
cool people where one of the people who
i met that summer ended up she's a
mentor to me to this day and she's
amazing and she was just someone where i
got her business card at a hackathon and
emailed hey it was nice to meet you and
now she was invited to my wedding she's
someone who i talk with regularly like
it just happened to be that way and so i
think i think the networking aspect is
something that really just uh helped
take off my career because even though
like networking doesn't get you
everywhere you still need to know how to
code you still need to know how to do
things being able to make those
connections with people is so vital for
just getting your foot in the door
sometimes and and i've been able to have
so many cool experiences because i've
been willing to go through all of the
emails of people who are at an event
send a nice to meet you and just
get to know some of those people
absolutely and so i want to dig into
something a little bit because
you have this
almost otherworldly ability to end up in
the room you just said you know your
junior year college you spoke at the
white house you are
part of a um like a react core team
community call where you kind of talk to
the react team about what should and
shouldn't happen in the community and
and you've got like you seem to be
involved in all of the things and
that we could just say oh well that's
just cassidy she's special but i don't
think that's true i think you work
really hard at that and so i'm i would
love to hear what what is it that you're
doing how are you making these
connections and and you know what what
did you do to get that invite to the
white house what are you doing to to get
invited to these calls with with
different community leaders and and you
know to do the mc work and all of this
you know the phrase that my mom always
says is squeaky wheel gets the grease a
lot of times it's just asking and being
loud about it and stuff and so like not
not just like getting invited to the
white house and and
getting invited to speak at the u.n
getting invited to to go to all these
cool places
that was stuff where truly there was for
example one of the things that i did
that junior summer that again changed
trajectory of my career it was a
hackathon on a plane and it was a flight
from san francisco to london and it was
all of these tech leaders on the plane i
was the only undergrad student on this
plane and the other people were so much
cooler than me like craig of craigslist
was on the plane megan smith who's cto
of the united states was on the plane uh
just uh kimberly bryant from black girls
code was on the plane all these really
cool people i found out the plane was
happening i emailed the organizers and i
said hey i'm really interested in this
do you have space for someone like me
and then i like sent them my resume and
they said actually some people just
dropped out sure we can fill your spot
wow that's a cooler spot like it was
truly me just asking and if you don't
ask you don't get really and so i a lot
of it is
just asking and and for example uh
getting to know the react team and
getting involved with with all these
technical groups a lot of times it was
just me sliding into the dms and saying
hey i'm really interested in this work
that you're doing i don't know if you
can ever use me but i think it would be
great to be involved in something like
this because i'm really interested in
the technology that you're using it
it's small but that's something that is
significant i remember when i was first
in my first tech job in brooklyn and i
would always go to the brooklyn js
meetup and and just getting to know
people there and uh i saw that at one of
the events john resig was going to be
there for those who don't know he made
jquery i dm'd him beforehand and i just
said hey john i saw you're going to be
at this meet-up i hope i meet you there
see ya left it at that and then at the
meet-up he approached me and i remember
i was with all my co-workers and he was
just like hey you're the one who dm'd me
it's so nice to meet you cassidy and
like that was truly the interaction the
street cred i got
when john resig approached me but well
it
it was significant because because he
approached me i got to have a
conversation with him and then people
who wouldn't normally talk to me
started talking to me because they saw
that i had this connection with someone
who's big in the industry yeah
and it's
it's something that i think is
undervalued in tech to just be willing
to kind of put your ego at the door and
just ask and just reach out and and talk
to people
you know you you brought up two things
that i think are really interesting the
the first one is
it would be really easy to chalk a lot
of this up to luck you you emailed that
hackathon on a plane and it just so
happened that somebody had dropped out
and they had space right so oh lucky but
this is i think a really good example of
creating your own luck um
because you know if if we look back on
this how many of these emails have you
sent that
got ghosted that went nowhere where you
gotta know
so many
constantly like there are sometimes
people on twitter i'm just like i
remember i dm'd them and they never dm'd
me back
and it's just like
just oh i forgot they existed they
probably never knew i did
that's just
that happens all the time but you never
know if someone will reply i i take the
same approach with raffles i apply to
every raffle i enter people think i win
a lot of raffles i've won quite a few
things that's how i got my kindle that's
how i got just like various lego sets
and stuff that i have you never know if
you could win your percentage is low but
you could get lucky and and i kind of
take the same approach with with that
kind of i take the same approach with
job uh interviews too when i was in
college i think i applied to over a
hundred maybe 200 jobs and people were
just like dang you got a lot of job
offers i'm like yeah but do you know how
many interviews i had to go to yeah
dozens and dozens and thousands of
interviews and sure i had like a decent
picking to choose from in the end but it
was because i did so many job interviews
yeah oh i think i mean that that is
such an important part that i think it's
it gets skipped a lot when we talk about
these because you know the
the happenstance or the chance
encounters or the the lucky break a lot
of times that happens because you do you
know hundreds of job applications or
send hundreds of of dms that go ignored
and
you know i i think that it can be really
easy to to send off one job request and
you don't hear anything back and you go
oh i must not be any good at this and
the fact of the matter is that like
you're only half of the equation you're
also waiting for someone to be at the
right place at the right time with the
right needs and so you have to create as
many of those opportunities as you can
to
to you know be the right person at the
right time to let people know that
you're available so when they have that
need they go oh i just talked to cassidy
she's looking for this kind of work we
should talk to her like that's you know
though i i i always
and maybe you'll you'll echo this but i
feel like i hear a lot of people who say
nothing's happening this doesn't work
i'm never gonna make it in this industry
and i always tell them i'm like
look it's
this is gonna feel like nothing's
happening and then it's all gonna happen
at once you just gotta keep showing up
yeah a friend of mine actually uh was
looking for a job for a solid year and a
half and nothing was happening and he
kept putting up feelers kept applying
and stuff and he finally started his
brand new job this week and he was so
excited because he was finally in this
startup and literally
three days after he started three of
those startups or three or four of those
startups that he had applied to suddenly
were just like hey we really liked
talking to you back in the day but we're
just now having openings and he's just
like well that timing is
nuts because it you know just like you
said you never know when that timing
will work out and so just it's a numbers
game absolutely all kinds of
opportunities and conversations and
things a lot of times it's truly just
putting it out there and seeing what
might come back yeah um and and that
actually i think is a nice kind of segue
into into something i'd love to talk to
you about in particular because i think
that you have
a really unique
presence on on uh everywhere that you
show up which is that you are
like legitimately funny and um and i
think that like
it's it it was when i first met you and
and i'm not saying that like oh i met
you and i thought you were funny and now
i don't but
but when i when i first met you i think
i would have assumed that you are just
like a naturally funny person and that
you know you you're just
everything that you see you're like i've
got a funny joke for that and you just
you just whip off zingers all the time
and what i've realized through through
you actually you taught our team how to
be funny which was i i love that um
but you you have this approach to
everything where you
repeatedly try
the same thing a little bit different
and where you're you're tweaking
approaches and and kind of assessing
that can you talk a little bit through
maybe not necessarily in humor but just
in like your approach in general um
how does that factor in to your career
do you think
yeah so
to that between between jokes between
project ideas between
pretty much everything i just write
everything down and and i have i have
both physical notebooks i have drawings
i have digital ones i have
managers of all kinds of things i write
absolutely everything down because you
never know if something might be useful
right and sometimes it's a code snippet
sometimes it's just a statement
sometimes it's look into this website
because this might be interesting
someday there there are so many
things where i i'm even still on
pinterest where i purely just put like
projects that i might want to do someday
just to see if something might land and
a lot of times it's me kind of prepping
for some day in the future that may
never come but
for for every joke for every tweet for
every
task i take on sometimes even jobs i
might want to apply to someday i write
them down because
it's it's kind of i guess it's kind of
like that second brain concept in a way
because there are times where you might
think of a good idea and just forget it
and i will forget things if i don't
write it down and and so
just getting it down on paper helps
remember it and then tagging things
properly organizing yourself properly
you never know when an idea you might
have one day might actually be the
perfect idea
years later yeah
um and and so as part of this too you
know you're you're writing everything
down you're keeping track of these ideas
uh but you're also
i would i would guess you know i know
for for me at least when i'm trying to
make jokes i spend a lot of time making
jokes that are only marginally funny or
not funny at all
and i learn like when i try it this way
it gets a little bit of a laugh if i
tweak it like this it gets a lot of a
laugh and i found similar things in my
in my career if i build a thing like
this people get it if i present it like
this people kind of recoil and back away
um
how would you say that that sort of
approach because i know that you're
you're similar and that you you try
things and tweak and try things and
tweak how does that affect your
confidence
you only get more confident over time
i think i think for example a good
example of this is i used to teach
workshops full-time for for react and
stuff and when i was first teaching i
was like man i know this material but i
am nervous for teaching people about it
we'll see how it goes and
it went decently at first and i was just
like okay you know what they asked those
questions so i'm going to try to make
sure this information is particularly
clear so the next workshop it's tweaked
ever so slightly and the more i did it
the more the the more refined it got
it's kind of like uh stand-up comedians
how they want their type 10. they they
rework a joke until it's funny enough
that that they consistently get a laugh
um there's this phrase that i like to
use repetition is recognition
try different approaches whether it's a
coding approach a humor approach a talk
approach a blog approach um
you you perfect it and and practice does
make perfect for pretty much everything
yeah
yeah i i think so a couple people in the
chat are asking about um how to build
confidence for tech interviews and would
you say that's you know
that's how you would recommend it or are
there other tips that you would
recommend 100 recommend it
again when i said it was a numbers game
like
every single interview is a practice
interview and like the i have done a lot
of interviews i i have interviewed at a
lot of places sometimes i interview even
when i'm not looking for a job just
because it's good practice and learning
how to present yourself in an interview
figuring out what kind of approaches do
and don't work
experiencing different interviewers
where you can kind of get a vibe is this
person someone who would kind of smirk
if you make a self-deprecating joke or
is this the kind of person who would
just like be stoic you kind of figure
out your approaches as you interact with
all of these different interviewers and
that really helps over time and and i
truly think that i'm decent at
interviewing not because i'm perfect at
getting merge sort and the proper
space and time complexity but because
i've done it so many times and because
i've interacted with interviewers so
many times that i know how to it feels
like gaming the system but really it's
just practice
absolutely yeah i found the same thing
like the the
one of the reasons that i run learn with
jason is because it forces me to
practice like i i get put into
situations with things i don't know and
i have to just figure it out and because
of that i feel like my stress tolerance
is so much higher because i just do it
all the time and i practice doing that
live stuff
um so there's a question in the chat
which i think is actually pretty
interesting um shidanza is asking what's
an effective way of practicing coding
and like what sort of intermediate goals
should you keep for that practice
so there's there's so many different
ways to practice coding and i guess it
depends on your goals and i hate
answering it depends when that is kind
of the answer but um so so for example
if you really want to get good at like
a certain type of algorithm or data
structure try implementing it in
different languages start implementing
it in pseudocode first implement certain
things in pseudocode first then do it to
python then ruby then javascript then
java and stuff figure out how you can
kind of solidify that information where
it's yes you're experimenting with
different languages but you're really
getting used to the structure of that
data you're really getting used to how
that algorithm should be meanwhile if
you're trying to really just get good at
javascript just constantly build things
with javascript i remember uh like i
there was a point where i was really
keen on maintaining my github streak and
i had like i think was 128 days on
github of just straight coding and a lot
of times my projects were just
dumb they were not they were not
particularly useful projects i was just
like you know what i want to just get
good at javascript and so i just tried
to build something with it every day and
sometimes it was a few lines of code
sometimes i'd get past that writer's
block and and write a ton of code um but
really it's just build something and and
there's so many ideas out there to build
and you can start with something basic
like a to-do list a book review app
something like that but then as as you
practice be like a chat app a reddit
clone
just just keep keep kind of copying
existing ideas while building it in your
own unique way to to really just
practice it and and for example i tried
to get better at css for a long time and
so i every single thursday i called it
codepen thursdays i'd build something on
codepen i'd get a design from dribble or
something and just try to recreate it
i'd give myself an hour sometimes it was
not perfect but it got me practicing and
and slowly but surely i got decent at
css because i was practicing it enough
and suddenly i was able to say okay well
if i know i need to center this these
are the three approaches i can take
and and just go with it and so truly
just code and it's hard to get started
but start with something dumb and basic
and just build up as you get ideas and
as you get an app idea that you want to
build write it down because then you can
use that idea later
yeah i and i think like what you're what
you're mentioning too there's also
another thing that you can do with that
which which you talked about briefly but
i want to dig into a little bit more
which is you were practicing but then
you created codepen thursdays and that
was something you could share
and so if you're trying to learn
something like one of my favorite
examples of this is lynne fisher she
does a project called a single div and
during october she does divtober and
every single day she makes a css
illustration or animation using
just css
most of the time in codepen and shares
it and as a result she's built huge name
recognition she's one of the like the
the first people you would think of if
you wanted to do beautiful css art you
would go oh we need lin fisher and
that's not because like that's not even
her job she's like an executive at a at
an agency or something and she just at
least she just does this because she
likes doing it and as a result she's
become a leading expert on it um how do
you feel that that sort of of
kind of exposing your work even if it's
not the best thing you've ever built how
has that impacted your career do you
think
learning in public is huge and and i
think i think that's something that
a lot of people should do i know it's
not for everybody so i don't want to say
everyone should do this but it gets your
name out there and sometimes that is
that is all you need to to
do something really well with your
career or do some make connections that
you need um an example of this honestly
is my father-in-law he he's
a 55-year-old korean man and he decided
he wanted to learn how to code three
years ago and so we were practicing with
him we were helping him learn and and as
he was building stuff he was just like
this is really interesting to me but he
was having trouble in interviews because
his english wasn't so great and he was
nervous about ageism and on all kinds of
stuff and we said okay how about this
start posting on twitter even if it's
even if it's just like i built this
today and no links or anything just
start posting regularly so that way so
that way your your name can be out there
a bit and
it worked there there was a point where
it was he did like a hundred days of
code where he would just say like today
i implemented n10 tests on this or today
today i struggled with this i don't know
if i'll be able to get it done but i'm
working on it that gave him practice
writing that gave him practice
explaining what he was working on that
gave him the recognition of oh yeah i
did accomplish something today and then
when he tweeted out that he was looking
for a job people who had been noticing
his tweets over time he he was able to
get on calls with them and and after
doing the job interview process which
took a very long time he started his
first job this year his first software
engineering job and he's killing it and
it's truly just from all the practice
and putting his name out there and and
it's something that he's not comfortable
with i don't think he's tweeted ever
since he got the job because like he's
like you know i've got my job i'm good
but that was enough just i'm set but uh
if you want to if you get your name out
there it's first of all again it tells
you that you did something it reminds
you that you did something even if it
was something hard but then it also kind
of puts it out there in the world where
if someone someday is trying to say man
i wonder if anybody has ever built
something like this before they might
find your project or they might find
your status they might ask you about it
and you never know what connections
might come from that yeah
yeah and and so i think um there was a
there was a question that i thought was
really interesting um which relates to
this which is you were you're saying
that he was learning how to like write
about what he's doing to communicate
what he's doing and uh elliot asks uh or
he just yeah he asked i realized lately
that i'm not selling myself well how
have you figured out how to sell
yourself and resonate with your
interviewers
that is a great question and
i i think uh that that is that is the
golden question really figuring out how
to sell yourself because
selling
cassidy williams is different from
selling jason langsdorff it's different
from selling sarah drazer everyone sells
themselves differently and so you have
to figure out kind of i
hate to use a cliche phrase but your
personal brand of how you want to pitch
yourself and i think figuring that out
involves many things first of all what
do you want to do but also what don't
you want to do um i think both are
equally important a lot of people are
just like okay i'm willing to do
anything to get a job you're not willing
to do anything
make sure you know what you actually do
want to do what you don't want to do and
and be able to figure out how to explain
what you can do what are you good at
what are you not that good at
there are things for example
i know i am not good at low level
languages like c and c plus i never want
to write those again there are times
where really cool jobs come up or i'm
just like man
programming robots that would be amazing
and then i have to remind myself no it
won't because i'll be working with these
languages that i don't want to work with
yeah it just sounds cool and stuff and
so knowing what you like knowing what
you don't like and figuring out your
like 30 second pitch this is what i can
do this is what i can't do and being
able to articulate that well for
yourself means that you can articulate
it well to other people as you practice
that pitch over and over um a lot of
times for that like 30 second pitch of
yourself whether you're going to a
career fair or you're or just talking to
interviewers and stuff uh practice with
your friends
i remember when i was in college even my
roommates and i we would just say okay
this is my 30-second pitch for myself
what do you think and i would just
introduce myself quickly explain what i
like to do explain the things that i'm
hoping to do
go and then
seeing what what they might say and then
uh be ready for those kinds of follow-up
questions and stuff and once again
practice does make perfect and figuring
out how to sell yourself does involve uh
maybe a few flops here and there and you
could be just like okay that approach
was not
great and so now i know not to do that
one well and that's where the the
repetition like creating your own look
right like if you know if you're gonna
become the best baker in the world you
don't just find one recipe and say okay
i'm probably done this is probably the
best bread right you have to make a
bunch of bad bread before you realize
what the common elements are that make
great bread
can you tell i'm hungry
i was just gonna say i could go for some
bread
but so i think
something that that i
would would kind of love to dig into
around this is like
when you are um
when you're talking about this to people
who aren't
super confident in coming out and
selling themselves right like i think
when you when you talk to a lot of folks
especially introverts the idea of
selling
gets really kind of skin crawly they're
like i don't want to sell anything i
don't like that idea
um
one one thing that i heard that i really
like and that i think you're very good
at is instead i i don't consider a lot
of what i'm doing to be selling i
consider it to be that i am
looking at what somebody is trying to
accomplish and i'm trying to match what
i know how to do with what their goals
are and then i'm i'm trying to connect
those dots between
where they are
what i can offer and how we can get
there so i'm not really selling myself
i'm trying to you know
paint this picture of what we could do
together
and
how like
i i guess
do you fi do you follow a similar
approach and and if so kind of how
how i don't how do you think about that
how does how does your brain wrap around
that sort of conversation that's my
exact approach to everything not just
not even just uh professional
conversations and stuff i figure out how
can i relate to you in a way that will
be interesting for you and that i can
continue to speak to and stuff and i
myself am a very introverted person like
i i give tech talks and stuff i'll
answer questions afterwards small talk
is terrifying
if you talk if you talk to high school
me
you should be shocked that i'm
a very public persona today just because
it's something that i never expected to
do and and
selling is terrifying but kind of like
what you said really all it is is
figuring out what will this person want
to hear what will this person respond to
and how can i show myself to them in a
way that they will respond to like how
do i frame all of this and i feel like
every time i'm at an event every every
time i'm i'm speaking to people whether
it's over zoom or over an interview or
anything it's it's figuring out okay
as they introduce themselves getting to
know them
figuring out their cadence of speaking
figuring out how they how they talk not
necessarily just mirroring it but seeing
okay this person does not seem to have a
sense of humor i'm gonna cut it out and
just try to you know
say it's say it straight but then there
are some people where you can tell like
oh they smirk a little bit now and then
okay i'll throw in a few dry jokes here
and there and see if they like it or
there's someone like you for example you
laugh at jokes and i appreciate that so
i know that i can just i can just throw
crap to the wind and i'll get a smile
out of it and it's great and we both
have a good time and so i i think
i i think that is a very
key way of just kind of getting to know
people and and you can build the
relationship after the initial
connection but sometimes the initial
connection is figuring out how can i
make this conversation work and and that
really is what selling is
yeah absolutely
um so i have a big departure because a
great question just came in muhammad
asks uh i already have work as a
software developer at a tech company but
i'm finding it hard to do side projects
and other ideas do you have any tips
i get that sometimes work is exhausting
and so at the end of the day you're just
like
i want to code but i can't and your
brain is just tired and i think i think
you have to figure out your schedule
then and and i know some people where
they are just exhausted at the end of
the day they can't fathom writing more
code and and doing stuff and so they
start their day with it and they're just
like okay you know what i'm gonna go to
bed an hour earlier i'm gonna wake up an
hour earlier and i'm just gonna code on
my own stuff and then get to work and
and and figuring out that kind of
schedule for yourself i think is really
really important because when you're
excited about an idea uh you could you
could code on that for ages but
sometimes you kind of need that kick in
the pants and so i i think for myself
like whenever i'm getting through that
slump or i'm just so tired at work but i
want to work on something myself i'll
start it in the morning go through my
work day but if i'm excited by what i
started in the morning i'll just work on
it after work then because i've already
got those juices flowing um and so i
think figuring out a schedule for
yourself is important there and
experimenting with different ones until
you find something that sticks yeah i
think like i i've heard it described as
as we have
a like a reservoir of
mental energy or willpower that we wake
up with every day and like if we don't
sleep enough that reservoir is is
more empty when we start um so getting
enough rest making sure that you are
kind of taking care of yourself
physically so that you can operate at
the right level and then being aware of
like what's taking those those like
what's sapping that energy because there
are a bunch of decisions that i don't
realize drain me that drain me intensely
like if i
have to
open up my fridge
and choose what to eat like i'm like
okay i have a bunch of ingredients i can
cook four meals what am i gonna cook
tonight that's actually like all of my
side project energy trying to think of
what i'm gonna cook so one of the ways
that i've started hacking that is by
making like a batch meal i'll make chili
or curry or or something that i can make
a lot of and then have ready so that i
don't have to use that energy on my
weeknights i can say okay i'm going to
eat curry tonight because that's what's
ready and then i'm going to work on my
side project because i still have the
gas in the tank to do that
um and so you know
what um
let's see there are so many questions
here that i want to make sure we want to
get time for um
but actually actually here's a question
that i think is really interesting
because everybody's routine is very
different and everybody's got different
like early bird night owl kind of
routines
what is your like typical
day how do you split up your time among
different projects and and work and all
the other things that you do
yeah and so i am one where i wake up and
i go straight to work like so sometimes
i will wake up
10 minutes before a meeting and just
get straight to work go
yeah yeah that's just how it is i wake
up and it's time for work but then as
soon as work is done i
depending on how the day was depending
on what i need to get done uh that's
when i start planning out everything and
and i do have a few projects where it's
not just a side project for myself but
it's something that i'm doing with
others for example i write the stack
overflow newsletter for that on on those
days i need to make sure that i write
that copy before a certain hour on a
certain day of the week otherwise i will
stay up all night just
taking way too long to just write this
dang copy and so i have to have a
dedicated time for that in the afternoon
um
even even stuff
the
small things like
writing tweets for work i have to have
set times for that because otherwise i
won't actually do it
but then outside of that it if it's a
project for myself or other things
i'll kind of eat food and dawdle a
little bit answering emails and stuff
but then it kind of depends on
what the project of the day is if it's
me starting something new i actually
almost never start a new project at my
desk because with all of my monitors and
stuff in front of me it's awesome
because i can do so many things at once
but when i want to start a brand new
project i almost always go to a chair go
to a couch or something and just sit
with my laptop and focus because if i
have this small screen in front of me
with just like classical music in the
background i can get all of my structure
set up have my ideas written out have a
notebook next to me to get it done and
that's that's how i focus and then once
i'm ready to like expand it a bit more
that's when i go back to my desk and
have the big stuff in front of me
because otherwise i will play fortnite
or something and and
chat on discord and stuff and not
actually get to work but
typically that's that's that's the day
if i'm starting a new project i'm away
from my desk otherwise i'm playing games
or working on something existing at my
desk um
yeah yeah i get that like if i if i even
look at the tv
my productivity is done for the day
right i just i i always tell myself i'm
like oh i'm going to watch one episode
of the great british baking show before
i go to bed or while i eat dinner and
then i'm like a full season and a half
and i'm like what have i done
all those soggy bottoms
yeah no
yeah it's
it's basically that and granted like
pandemic work is different from remote
work i just described a pandemic typical
day outside of
outside of that it totally depends
because normally i see people and and i
might go to an actual physical meetup
and stuff there's there's a lot more
uh there's a lot more things to do when
there are things to do but when you're
at home in a pandemic it's basically am
i looking at a big screen or a medium
screen or a small screen
all the time
i know i yeah that's
i am very much looking forward to
getting back to regular remote work and
not pandemic work i know
um
so
to to flip this on its head a little bit
like you are you're very senior in your
career you're uh you're a principal in
your job now and you act as a you know
you you do mentorship you've worked in
hiring capacities you have led teams so
i want to turn this a little bit the
other way and i want to talk about like
if you're looking for someone that
you're going to give your time to or
that you're going to give an opportunity
to
what have you seen that's helped
somebody
show that it's someone you want to
invest that time into like how are
people
how are people making it visible that
that they're somebody that you want to
give that chance to
first of all i
it's one of my biggest pet peeves when
someone dms and it's just like hey i'd
like you to be my mentor
i'll just
that is not how this works i it's it's
oh that drives me crazy because that
relationship isn't real it's just you
wanting something out of that person and
so i think
starting with a relationship first is
key and and starting with that it often
just involves a question and and i'll
use an example of of a mentor of mine
her name is kelly hoey she's awesome she
wrote a book on networking um
she is the person who i first met my
junior year summer where i got her
business card at a hackathon i emailed
her hey it was nice to meet you i saw
her at a few other events and stuff and
slowly over time i would just email her
on occasion saying kelly i really hope
that you're well this is what i'm doing
i'm graduating soon blah blah blah hey
i'm in my first job i'm thinking about
asking for a raise for the first time do
you have any tips for me i kind of would
just
be
present and stuff but i wouldn't ask
anything of her except unless i had a
very specific question right and over
time we would actually start hanging out
we would actually start meeting up and
and she would say hey actually i need
someone to speak at this event will you
help me here and then sometimes i would
say hey i actually need some advice in
this regard can you help me here and it
became kind of a two-way relationship it
wasn't just me trying to get whatever i
could out of her and a lot of times when
i see mentorships fail it's because it's
someone who just wants something out of
a person and they're just like okay
check in with me once a month to see how
i'm doing and you can coach me as if
it's
as as if you're hiring them to do free
labor and and that's that's not what
mentorship is about mentorship is
getting to know someone
in a relationship a friendship where
they just they just happen to be further
ahead in in their career and there are
so many people who i've mentored where
we've never actually said the word
mentorship before it's just it's just
something where
i happened to help them out a few times
because they asked specific questions or
they were in this chat room and they
were saying hey would someone mind
reviewing my resume and i would be just
like yeah i got time i would do that and
then we just kind of started talking
more and more and that's just how it
ended up being it it has to be a lot
more natural than a mentorship proposal
it's got to be some kind of
some some kind of like actual back and
forth and so when i'm
when i'm looking for
people to help out and everything i
don't really actively seek out like who
will be the next mentee of cassidy i
don't i don't do anything like that will
you accept this rose
yeah no nothing like that uh it's it's
truly just i hang out in chat rooms i'm
i'm on twitter a lot and stuff and
people will ask me questions on occasion
and
if it's if it's not like a full essay if
it's because i get enough dms i can't
read every essay that comes my way um
i'll answer it and and sometimes we just
chat a few times on occasion sometimes
they'll send me their resume a couple
times and stuff and then
eventually we just kind of have this
relationship where we're just chatting
on occasion and i occasionally help them
and then they'll retweet my stuff and
and it becomes a little back and forth
and so
it
i guess if you are looking for a mentor
don't actively be just like who will be
the one who will guide me
just
put have a presence in certain
communities and kind of put out there
that you're learning put out there that
you want your resume looked at or that
you're not sure what to do here
occasionally post questions and as
people start answering the questions the
the mentors kind of come out of the fold
quickly when you're in these kind of
community discords for example um there
are there are sometimes chats where
people would just like hey does anybody
know anything about this i i'm new to
writing golang and i'm really curious
about how this kind of stuff works as
people answer your questions you can be
just like okay great and then you can
ask more questions again in the future
eventually you'll see who keeps who
continually replies you can occasionally
dm them a really nice thank you saying
thank you to people oh my god
just say thank you it's huge it's so
easy and it goes so far it goes so far
there are so many times where i've just
sent very simple thank you notes
over email or something and people will
reply back saying you know this is the
first time someone's ever thanked me for
this i i really appreciate it thank you
like there's just
it means so much to people to see that
their efforts to help you didn't go
unseen like you didn't just say thanks
and then and then bounce yeah and so
really just be
be a giving person and be a be a
grateful person and and be a part of
your communities because the mentors
will come out of the fold as you uh
start helping and sometimes your mentor
is the community and and it's it's just
a group thing where you're helping each
other you know that actually i think
that hit so close to home for me because
one of the things that i've realized
as you know i i went from being somebody
who was brand new to the industry i you
know i lived in montana i didn't have
any connections and i would see people
who gave keynotes or who
worked at the companies that i wanted to
work at and i would think oh my god
these must be like celebrities i
remember thinking that paul irish
probably like had a malibu mansion and
and you know like was the and like he
might but he but at the same time i
don't i haven't met a single person in
tech who's got a name who is walking
around thinking like
you know
i'm pretty great everybody should well i
guess i have met people like that but in
general like there are there's nobody
walking around going like i am a mentor
and you are the mentees it's it's very
much like there's a community
and
it it feels
awkward to me when somebody says
can you be my mentor because i don't
feel like i am
i don't feel like i'm qualified to do
that i'm just a dude writing code um and
like i know some things but i don't know
way more things
and so what i found is that when the
community is built around this idea of
knowledge share and like knowledge
transfer and everybody is participating
then it starts to become a really good
like
co-mentoring or just like co-growth
scenario as opposed to uh
it doesn't it shouldn't be pedagogical
like if i put together a workshop great
come learn from me but if i'm just being
a person
i don't what i don't want to give
lectures i don't want to
like sit you down and try to teach you
something i want to talk to you like a
person like i want my online existence
is about having friends not about having
students and i think that that is um
that's something that if if we can get
out of the mindset of like there are
people who are here and they're the rest
of us down here
it levels that playing field you can
talk to somebody like a human and you
have such a better chance if you just
ask a question and then if you know
something offer some advice and support
um it's yeah i i and that that's
actually something that i really like is
you know you've got your your discord
for like your twitch subscribers your
patreon supporters and
that's not like
cassidy holding court it's
hanging out with people
right it truly is and and like there
there have been some people who have
when i've said oh my my patreon discord
group is so great they're just like ah
this is an interesting business model a
thought leader letting people in on
their deep secrets i'm just like no
that's not what it is really it's just a
great discord group where because
there's a two dollar entrance fee
quote unquote there's less spam that's
that's truly that's truly what it is and
and the group is so
helpful to each other it's such a nice
community and and people are are really
really giving and and i think
i think that is really really important
to realize
yeah all of these people who you think
are up here they're just people they
just have more dms that's that's all it
really is
that's such a good question yes
absolutely that's exactly what it is
same person worse dms um
uh so i saw a couple good questions come
in that i that i want to look at so
because you've been involved with hiring
developers what are the biggest mistakes
that you've seen like what are the
things that really like grind on you so
you mentioned one of them like saying
will you be my mentor but what what else
have you seen oh i've seen i've seen so
many things it just oh i've got stories
out the wazoo some more extreme examples
but for example an extreme example is
one time someone applied to a job where
i was reviewing the resumes and stuff
after they had gone through a few loops
i was like oh this resume looks good and
i went to look at their personal website
and it was my personal website like all
they did was change the name and the bio
but like it was my code they even kept
my comments in and stuff and i was like
what are you thinking
and then uh
there was one time where
i
was interviewing a person in person they
were doing whiteboarding
and they just started crying part way
through and i felt i felt really bad and
i know i know it's like high pressure
and stuff but then when i tried to say
here i can change the question or here's
a kleenex or don't worry about it they
would say no and then just put their
hand up and wouldn't let me talk and we
literally sat there in silence while
they cried for 45 minutes whoa it was
terrible so these are very extreme
examples
but i think they they are
very very key to
their they're indicative of certain
things so first of all things that i
don't like to see i don't like to see
people who are not open for feedback
if if you say no or something or
someone's trying to help you out or
something that's that is a red flag if
someone's crying an interview in an
interview i understand it is high
pressure
but don't take it out on the interviewer
just just uh
just be willing to
take your time to get calm and then work
on it again it's that that would have
been fine but it was because of that
reaction that it wasn't great um for for
a personal website if you're gonna just
straight up copy a personal website at
least give credit don't take work and
then pass it off as your own and then
yes and that is that is something that
oh it peeves me because i've seen that
not just for myself but so many people
where they they claim that they're like
the world's best developer or whatever
and then
you see that their code is not their own
it's it's frustrating and so really a
lot of it is putting your ego at the
door
um don't
be willing to get feedback be willing to
admit both strengths and weaknesses um
and
what i really love in interviews is if i
ask a question and someone like is
working on and stuff and then they just
admit
they say honestly i'm not entirely sure
how to do this normally this is
something i would google i love that
honesty
so much
i don't hold it against them at all
because that's something that
it's true there are times where i have
to google the most basic javascript
things even though i've been using
javascript for like 15 years it
sometimes you just need to google it and
and so i love seeing that kind of
honesty and and lack of ego and
humbleness when you're in an interview
setting
yeah i i
would just echo that a thousand times i
think that's such a
that's such an important thing is to
just like
you know again be a person like you're
not selling
the the
10 of your brain that knows
programming you're selling your entire
existence you're gonna be
you know your your sense of humor you're
gonna be your your strengths your
weaknesses all of that stuff and showing
that is what makes people feel like
you're a human you know it's one of the
things that i that i think is so
um
it's it's what makes someone online kind
of magnetic it's why we follow certain
accounts not because of
you know because of their technical
content like i follow a lot of people
who write code that i don't understand
they're java programmers or they they
write you know they're doing machine
learning stuff i don't do that i can't
really follow their examples but oh my
god do i love to watch them they're just
so engaging they're so fun they're
they're whole humans and that's actually
kind of how i started following you was
because of your
uh your tick tock and so maybe this is a
good question to to kind of end on but
i feel like authenticity
is a really loaded word right we we say
that and it becomes more of a marketing
term
but
in the sense of of
you and your
kind of existence as a human and online
um
how much do you think
bringing all of yourself versus just the
technical part has influenced your
career
i think
the moment i started to bring more of
myself out there is when my career
really started to take off
or not even my career just online
presence and stuff in general like i've
always been making silly videos and
jokes since i was since i could operate
a camcorder because i started on
camcorders back in the day and and uh i
i would always just like be silly with
all kinds of things i was always into
building cool stuff like mechanical
keyboards but on my twitter on my
facebook all over the place i only
talked about code
about a year and a half ago or whatever
when i started making these funny videos
and decided to tweet about them
that's when suddenly
my online presence just shot up that's
when suddenly people were just like were
actually following me and everything
because it wasn't just coding content it
was fun coding content it was humor it
was me talking more about keyboard
suddenly it was it was a bit more
interesting to see and i think
and i'm not trying to like toot my own
horn like because i'm hilarious now i
have hundreds of thousands of followers
it's not that what i'm saying is
by being authentic suddenly people
actually cared what i had to say and i
think that's really indicative of a lot
when i see that people are tweeting
about all kinds of things and they're
not just sticking to tech i i love
seeing that and it
i've seen some people where like they'll
tweet a picture with their kids and i've
seen people reply saying uh stick to
tech i follow you for tech news you
don't want those kinds of followers
anyway you have people who who want to
get to know you and stuff and so and so
ignore those people i love seeing people
who
talk about their interests outside of
tech on the internet like granted i love
seeing the technical content i will read
almost every technical blog i can see
and write things down and stuff so that
way i can read more about it but when i
see for example on your channel how
you have your learn with jason stuff but
you also talk about like cooking and
everything i love learning about that
and seeing what different interests
people have i love seeing when people
are interested in korean dramas because
i can say oh have you seen this one yet
or i love when people are interested in
drawing because i would love to be a
better artist but i'm just not and and
just seeing how they draw and and use
that side of their brain i think is so
cool um
when i when i follow people a lot of the
people that i follow on twitter and on
instagram and stuff they might be tech
people but they're almost always
something else they're they're rarely
just someone who contributes to open
source a lot and and it's because i
appreciate seeing the authenticity of
someone who
doesn't just code all the time who's
interested in other things and and it's
cool to see the cool side projects and
stuff don't get me wrong i love seeing
when someone launches something cool
coding wise but seeing people do
other things and and put their whole
self out there in the workplace and out
of the workplace i think is very very
huge
uh and and i think is
important because
it
allows you to
have a work-life balance built in
because you go to an employer and they
know that this is who you are like i
know a gal where she
um she was working at yahoo and she
reviewed operas on the side she's
actually
she she's an opera viewer like
that is her side gig she she reviews
operas around the world she's awesome
and her every single job interview she
talked about it because people know in
her workplace
if she says i have to be out of here by
4 pm today because i have to go to this
opera they know this is her thing right
and and so that is built into her
schedule she has kind of a built-in
work-life balance because she brought
her whole self to the table
online in the interview and and
elsewhere and so i think it's really
important to be authentic about that
saying i'm a parent saying i
like to build keyboards saying i like to
stream or play video games and stuff
being willing to put yourself there
it it sets an expectation that work is
not your life and and i think that's
really important work is not your life
is such a good ending point for this i
think so i'm not even gonna try to
follow that up so instead what i'm gonna
say is thank you so so much for taking
the time to hang out with us today and
sharing all of this wonderful insight
into who you are and and how we can take
some inspiration from from what you've
done to try to expand our own careers um
what i am gonna do is i'm gonna drop a
couple things here uh so for anyone who
wants to you can find cassidy live on
twitch at twitch.tv slash kassadoo or on
twitter at twitter.comcassadoo
and i believe you're cassadoo like
everywhere right yeah yeah
github codepen all of those things all
of those things and uh and if you want
to see more live content from me i'm
going to be back with more episodes of
connecting the dots every friday from
now up until the holiday break
and i also do a live stream at
learnwithjason.dev that is a twitch live
stream a couple times a week cassidy's
been on it you can see past episodes
that learn with jason.dev um
youtube free code cam thank you all so
much for hanging out with us today
cassidy thank you again for spending
your valuable time with us i very much
appreciate it um any parting words for
everyone
keep memeing keep dreaming
it was it was very fun being on the show
thank you for having me and it was it
was lovely seeing seeing the chat and
everything people are asking if i play
among us i do i actually streamed some
last night um but yeah
hang out yeah
come find us on twitter we got links all
over the place we will see you next time
bye